mais vous n'allez pas aider les moteurs
temps et ces vidéos que les parents
ils ne l'ont pas
[Musique]
avec mon fils pour les femmes pour
nous aimons tous Enrique
nous t'aimons papa avec moi pas moi
Ça n'a pas d'importance pour moi, je m'en fiche si tu viens de
canaris
normal
et je n'ai pas
c'est beaucoup avec ça dans cette situation
dans une dépression que nous soutenons dans
Nous vous aimons tellement
Ça fait très mal mais rien d'autre pour ça
et je suis très fier de toi
pourquoi être
parce que tu es un bon étudiant
Je sais que tout le monde quand nous finissons est
voyant je sais que tout le monde me regarde
différent pour mon style
Eh bien, ça ne te dérange pas, tu sais quoi
Je dis des erreurs mais elle les aimait
ton style comment ils s'habillaient si je lui disais
merci
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas toujours prêt
on coupe différemment
[Musique]
pour